so ist sie auch weiter hier 60 minuten
der tagesordnung des bundestages am
nachmittag
als kommunikationsmittel der
demokratiebewegung im iran
beispielsweise sich jetzt aber im visier
der deutschen justiz der
messenger-dienst telegramm der steht in
deutschland und in anderen ländern als
plattform für auch rechtsextreme und
radikale gegner von corona maßnahmen
massiv in der kritik über ihn werden
zunehmend das sagen auch die
sicherheitsbehörden mit leben
kommunikation auch hass und hetze
verbreitet die bundesregierung will das
nicht will sich nicht damit abfinden
dass das hotel beispielsweise löcher
frage aus deutschland ignoriert und
versucht seit monaten auch juristisch
dagegen vorzugehen die afg fraktion hat
einen antrag hier vorgelegt und
sagt die angekündigten maßnahmen der
bundesregierung diese ein rechtswidrig
mit der abschaltung als ultima ratio
markus söder stimmte ihr zu und fordert
wird das bio blocking und der
niedersächsische innenminister boris
pistorius wollte den messenger-dienst
aus den app stores verbannen die politik
scheint sich eigentlich telegramm ist
gefährlich telegramm muss weg wenn sich
der macher von telegramm nicht den
wünschen der deutschen regierung beugt
nun pawel dotschew der gründer von tele
krank der kennt dieses vorgehen schauen
allerdings nicht von westlichen
demokratien denn bisher sind lediglich
länder wie china weißrussland russlands
oder der iran gegen telegramm
vorgegangen dass die bundesrepublik
tatsächlich mit dem gedanken spielt sich
in diese liste einzureichen ist eine
schande für unser land meine damen
nun ist offenbar eine doppelmoral die
ihresgleichen sucht denn vor zwei jahren
hatte die deutsche politik noch einen
sehr positiven blick auf telegramm ich
erinnere an das lob als sich
oppositionelle in weißrussland darüber
organisiert haben und jetzt ist elegant
zu einem der wichtigsten
kommunikationskanäle in der ukraine
geworden ukrainische telegramm kanäle
sind meistens in zwei sprachen die
ukrainisch in russisch und in englisch
und so bekommen auch hier mit was dort
los ist und dadurch nutzen auch viele
menschen in russland um auf nachrichten
zuzugreifen die nicht der staatlich
sanktionierten version der ereignisse
und sprechen
pavillons sagte neulich von neun jahren
habe ich die privatsphäre der ukraine
gegen die russische regierung verteidigt
und verloren meine firma und mein
zuhause
ich wurde ohne zu zögern wieder so
handeln so spricht jemand dem die
freiheit wirklich etwas bedeutet der
sich macht haben entgegen stellt und die
rechte der bürger schützt auch wenn er
dafür opfer bringen muss doch in
deutschland lobt man den einsatz von
telegramm in der ukraine
aber sobald sich die
außerparlamentarische opposition in
deutschland über telegramm organisiert
wird der messenger die plötzlich zum
problem für die politik und da steht ein
verbot von telegramm zur debatte es wird
druck auf apple und google ausgeübt
damit sie der app mit rausschmiss thron
und nichts unversucht gelassen ganze
kanäle zu sperren das sogar
justizminister marco buschmann von der
fdp betonte dass das netz wie
verbindlich sei selbstverständlich auch
für telegramm gelte und er den
messenger-dienst strenger kontrollieren
will macht eine handvoll ins fassungslos
war es doch die fdp die in der letzten
legislaturperiode
mehrfach die abschaffung des netzwelt
durchsetzungs gesetz gefordert hat alles
vergessen
ich frag mich wie sie morgens noch in
den spiegel gucken können werte kollegen
die abschalt forderung zeigt auch wie
wenig kraft wissen vorhanden ist
russland hat das mit der abschaltung
bereits versucht die haben 18 millionen
ip adresse blockiert in der hoffnung
telegramm abschalten zu können das
ergebnis staatliche webseiten war nicht
mehr erreichbar bankdienstleistungen ki
systeme online-speicher überall kam es
zu ausfällen und täter wechselte einfach
die server und machte weiter russlands
gab irgendwann auf die stadt hatte
gewonnen dafür sollen sie nun in
deutschland beschnitten werden dabei
geht es um kontrolle die menschen sollen
sich nicht ohne aufsicht vernetzen die
menschen sollen sich nicht zu verabreden
nicht zu spaziergängen und nicht zu
protesten die regierung hat angst vor
der eigenen bevölkerung
meine damen und herren die abschaltung
von tele haben in deutschland wäre ein
fatales signal für die welt gerade in
der heutigen zeit ganz davon abgesehen
dass der europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte ein solches vorgehen als
rechtswidrig eingestuft hat das scheint
der innenministerin entfallen zu sein
die fdp bundestagsfraktion fordert daher
von der bundesregierung kein verbot und
keine netzsperren für telegramm keine
anwendung das letzte google und apple
nicht unter druck zu setzen dass die
legale software anwendungen aus ihrem
stores werfen und stattdessen die mittel
des rechtsstaates zu verbessern und
dafür zu sorgen dass mehr polizisten und
staatsanwälte eingestellt und gesondert
geschult werden damit sie auch im netz
ihren job machen können denn im internet
gelten die gleichen gesetze wie in der
analogen welt liebe kollegen schützen
sie mit uns das von der verfassung
garantierte recht auf meinungsfreiheit
auch im internet und auf messenger
diensten und stimmen sie unserem antrag
zu herzlichen dank
futter für die fdp-fraktion die afg hat
diesen antrag hier vorgelegt die
bundesregierung ist seit einigen monaten
gegen telegramm juristisch vorgegangen
das verfahren dreht sich beispielsweise
um faire meldewege wenn es heißt was und
hätte im netz geht um gegen politikerin
sowie experten aus wissenschaft und
medizin die sich beispielsweise bei der
bewältigung der cola
[Applaus]
engagiert für präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen den
demokratischen parteien sehr geehrte
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger es handelt
sich bei telegramm doch längst nicht
mehr um einen reinen messenger dienst
für individuelle kommunikation telegramm
nutzen heute weltweit mehr als eine
halbe milliarde menschen es gibt offene
und geheime telegramm gruppen in denen
man in text ton und bild kommuniziert es
können telegramm kanäle mit unbegrenzter
abonnentenzahl angelegt werden telegramm
das in soziale netzwerke auf einer
digitalen plattform aber auch auf
digitalen plattformen gelten unsere
menschen und grundrechte sie kennen
keine trennung von online- und
offline-welt sie müssen sowohl in der
analogen als auch in der digitalen welt
angewendet werden
natürlich auch auf denen genau gilt das
recht auf freie meinungsäußerung es wird
auch nicht durch dunkle meinungen
verwirkt aber systemkritische und für
manche gefährliche meinungen sind
auszuhalten aber selbst die freiheit von
meinungen findet ihre grenzen an dem
punkt wurde menschliche würde und andere
gesetze verletzt werden
wenn man dem körper ist faschismus keine
meinung auch gewaltfantasien sind keine
meinung man muss es ganz klar sagen
nicht alles was man von sich gibt ist
deine meinung deren äußerungen durch
grundgesetz geschützt ist
wir setzen das und gewalt aufrufen oder
bewusste falschinformationen verbreitet
mag sich vielleicht selbst im gebrauch
seiner meinungsfreiheit sehen aber
tatsächlich ist es dir missbrauch
in manchen telegramm kanälen wird offen
zu hass und gewalt aufgerufen bis hin zu
mord und starts um stolz zu finden sind
auch gewalt aufrufe gegen politikerinnen
und wissenschaftlerinnen genauso wie
anleitungen zum waffenbau alles
kriminelle taten gegen die sich eine
demokratie werden muss
und wir tragen sich der ambivalenten
charakter von telegramm und unser
dilemma hier in der demokratie kann eine
plattform wie telegramm das
gesellschaftliche system schwächen in
diktaturen und autokratien bedeuten sie
oft den einzigen weg einer freien
kommunikation der zivilbevölkerung ohne
überwachung und repression
gerade heute in bezug auf die ukraine
und russland ist es notwendig einen
dissidenten kanal für demokratie fördern
da sicher zu stellen in autoritären
staaten ist der liga dass aber ein
wichtiger kanal für menschen die für
eine solche freiheitliche demokratie
unter gefahr für leib und leben und
deshalb anonym und im geschützten raum
kämpfen müssen
wie lässt sich also meinungsfreiheit
sicher hätte aber unterbinden wie lässt
sich kommunikationsfreiheit auf der
einen seite und klare regelungen gegen
desinformationen drohungen und aufruf zu
straftaten auf der anderen seite
gleichzeitig umsetzen das ist eine
komplexe frage wie man abwägen
differenziert betrachten nun beantworten
muss diese schritte sucht man bei der
afg vergebens
der einzige wichtige welt geht schlicht
und einfach über unsere grundrechte
genauso wie wir es sind analog seit
beginn des grundgesetzes tun dürfen auch
die digitalen plattformen kein
rechtsfreier raum bleiben das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz in deutschland und
vielmehr der digital services akt in der
europäischen union müssen uns alle
nötigen rechtlichen instrumente zur hand
geben damit auch telegramm nicht im
rechtsfreien raum bleibt
wir müssen wir müssen wir auf social
media statt in denen radikalisierung und
enthemmung offensiv begegnen zugleich
arbeite kontrolle maßhalten belohnen die
gefahr für unsere demokratie abwenden
wir wollen nicht die menschen bestrafen
die telegramme ist eine ganz normale
kommunikationsplattform nutzen
die die behörden habe auch ich den
verdachtsfall warum stellt die ard heute
einen solchen antrag ihr ruf nach
demokratie freiheit und menschenrechten
so darüber hinwegtäuschen dass die
einschränkungen von telegramm diensten
den nährboden für diejenigen bewegungen
entziehen würde die die afg aus ihrer
überlebensgarantie und
vorfeldorganisationen dringend braucht
aber unsere demokratie braucht sie nicht
unsere demokratie ist wehrhaft sie
basiert auf starken grundrechten wie wir
auch im digitalen raum durchsetzen
müssen vielen dank
[Applaus]
bisher autoritären staaten ein wichtiges
kommunikationsmittel
sagte hier
noch einmal zander martens für die spd
fraktion
es geht in deutschland carsten müller
hat das wort bei dem was die
bundesregierung jetzt vortag im hass und
hetze zu unterbinden welche
möglichkeiten es da gibt
es gibt von anderen fraktionen als der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion immer wieder
überlegungen das netzwerk durchsetzungs
gesetz für die regulierung von
individual kommunikation über messenger
dienste heranziehen zu wollen in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode gab es
einen ansatz der fdp vielleicht für den
einen oder anderen etwas überraschend
aber die fdp wurde damals trotz weg
regulieren die kommunikation darüber
dass das habe ich damals schon gesagt
ist mit der union nicht zu machen nun
gibt es diese überlegungen bezüglich
telegramm auch beim aktuellen
justizminister auch die
bundesinnenminister enteilt
offensichtlich ähnliche vorstellung
allerdings das netzwerk schließt
ausdrücklich aus nämlich plattform die
zur individual- kommunikation bestimmt
sind in den anwendungsbereich des netzes
einzubeziehen die private kommunikation
zwischen bürgern und bürgern in unserem
land unterliegt zu recht hohe hürden
hohen schutz würden solche
grundrechtswidrigen ansinnen solche
grundrechtswidrigen ansehen können
übrigens nicht ausschließlich aus der
fdp auch ein spd landesinnenministern
hat die vorstellung
bio blocking anzubinden das heißt nichts
anderes als
netzsperren und ehrlich gesagt dessen
bedarf es gar nicht weil auch schon
heute hass und hetze
erfolgversprechend in forschung des
gedankens der störerhaftung in diesen
kommunikationskanälen gekämpft und
diesen begegnet werden können es gibt
also gute möglichkeiten das ganze
verfassungskonform zu regionen in den
griff zu bekommen und ich will auch
eines ganz deutlich zum ausdruck bringen
für die unionsfraktion für uns steht es
außer frage dass plattform
betreiberinnen betreiber und allerdings
auch messenger dienste jetzt von diesem
erwartet werden muss dass sie kooperativ
mit deutschland wurden zusammenarbeiten
wer das verweigert das soll ja auch
deutlich gesagt werden der begibt sich
in den anschein dass er es mit der
rechtsordnung in diesem land nicht so
genau nehmen und das können wir nicht
dulden
ich fühle mich noch bei dem sich noch
einmal der antragstellerinnen fdp
fraktion zu finden da gibt es nämlich
einige einige besonderheiten das fängt
schon in der ersten zeile unter dem wort
antrag an schauen sie sich mal die namen
an die sie dort finden sie finden dort
den namen des abgeordneten eugen schmidt
beugen schmidt ist innerhalb des
bundestages nummer eins propagandist des
kriegsverbrechers putin innerhalb des
bundeslandes es gibt außerhalb des
bundestages und außerhalb der afg andere
putin freunde andere propagandisten aber
wie gesagt dann außerhalb des
bundestages
dieser kollege schmidt bestreitet in
putin russischen staatsmedien aktuell
dass deutschland ein rechtsstaat sei und
verbreitet folgende einlassungen ich
will sie mal zitieren damit wir wissen
wer diesen antrag geschenkt hat
schmidt es gibt keine demokratie in
deutschland dh es wird eine einheitliche
meinung aufgedrängt und zwar von der
regierenden elite und allen anderen
politischen meinungen werden mit den
möglichen mitteln unterdrückt im
internet in den medien unter anderem
auch durch körperliche übergriffe auf
andersdenkende
damit nicht genug nächstes beispiel
die medien in deutschland werden
selbstverständlich komplett von der
regierung kontrolliert das würde die
nutzung nicht zu lassen hat
alternative oppositionelle meinung sind
nicht vertreten meine damen und herren
dabei liefert eben diese eugen schmid
selber das beste beispiel dass das was
erzählt hat komplett der realität den
vollständigen unsinn ist vollständig ist
denn dann hätte etwas ansonsten nicht
sagen können er kann nämlich diesen
zynischen unsinn
vollkommen ungestraft verbreiten wenn er
an dieser debatte teilnehmen wird und
sich als redner
hätte vormerken lassen dann sogar hier
vom regen meine damen und herren
ganz anders sieht es übrigens mit dem
mut und der notwendigkeit meinungs und
pressefreiheit zu schützen aus wenn wir
uns die russische journalistin marina
auch sie an die korbacher anschauen ich
will das ganz ehrlich sagen ich glaube
ich hätte diesen mut nicht gerade
in einer sendung des russischen
staatsfernsehens dieses transparent
laufzeit
für fünf sekunden wichtigste wirkung
riskiert sie 15 jahre lang gut an dass
dieser
[Applaus]
übrigens hat sich der kollege schmidt
einen tag nach verschärfung dieser
strafandrohung nämlich strafandrohung
dafür dass man in russland die wahrheit
sagt entsprechend wie ich ihn zitiert
habe
eingelassen meine damen und herren ist
geradezu grotesk dass ausgerechnet eine
fraktion deren geschäftsmodell auf hetze
hass und falschinformationen basiert
dass ausgerechnet eine solche fraktion
sich hier zum thema meinungsfreiheit
bossert ist grotesk aber weil wir diese
meinungsfreiheit haben ist es nicht
verboten und ich will noch ein letztes
sie fallen ja regelmäßig mit ihnen ihren
äußerungen durch ein geradezu hündische
anbietern gegenüber dem kriegsverbrecher
putin auf und dieser kriegsverbrecher
putin teaser kriegsverbrecher putin der
benutzt als vorwand dienen argumente
angeblichen entnazifiziert bemerkenswert
ist dass wenn er das machte diese
investition gerade in ihren reihen große
lücken schlagen wird vielen dank
sagt kaske für die cdu csu fraktion in
richtung der fraktion
als nächste hat jetzt tabea rößner das
wort 90 die grünen ist sie vorsitzende
im ausschuss für digitales
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren wir
kennen das ja schon aus der letzten
wahlperiode vfb spielt sich als die
einzige verfechterin der
meinungsfreiheit auf wir wissen auch
dass das alles andere als glaubwürdig
ist denn sie beschimpfen andersdenkende
sie hetzen gegen menschengruppen und sie
diskreditieren journalistinnen und
unabhängige medien
das zeigt was sie unter meinungsfreiheit
verstehen dieses verständnis teil der
großteil dieses hauses und auch der
bevölkerung nicht
denn
wenn ein abgeordneter aus ihren reihen
sagt und ich zitiere auch nochmal mit
erlaubnis der präsident in den
abgeordneten schmidt ich habe mir das
zitat auch angeschaut die medien werden
in deutschland ich finde es schlimm
genug dass solche zitate zu lesen sind
die medien werden in deutschland
selbstverständlich komplett von der
regierung kontrolliert
alternative oppositionelle meinungen
sind nicht vertreten zitat ende dann
frage ich in welcher welt leben sie
eigentlich
allein dass sie solchen unfug verbreiten
können zeigt doch dass sie ihre meinung
frei äußern können und das ist manchmal
echt schwer zu ertragen aber das hält
die demokratie aus
der abgeordnete setzt eben noch drauf
und behauptete die regierende elite
unterdrücke alle anderen meinungen mit
allen möglichen mitteln und verfolge in
deutschland andersdenkende mit gewalt
das meine damen und herren statt hass
auf politiker innen das können wir so
nicht stehen lassen nach dem mord an
walther lücke nach halle nach hanau
wissen wir welche taten folgen können
und das zu verhindern ist unsere aufgabe
dem stellen wir uns als demokratinnen
und demokraten entschieden ist entgegen
und das war auch der grund daran liegen
dass hat das netzwerk durchsetzungs
gesetz damals verabschiedet wurde und
dieses anliegen war und ist berechtigt
denn auch sozialen netzwerken gibt es
ein massives problem mit rechtswidrigen
inhalten mord und gewalt aufrufe
extremistische und antisemitische
inhalte gehören dort so tagesordnung
accounts von demokratie freundin von
rechtsextremen gruppen oder von pandemie
leutner innen erreichen dort
sechsstellige follower zahlen und bei
der vernetzung dieser gruppen spielt
telekom eine entscheidende rolle in
diesem dunstkreis mischen sie mit das
zeigen äußerungen von fdp politikern zum
umsturz und bürgerkriegs fantasien auf
telegramm sie sind daher weniger der
tapfere ritter im kampf gegen zensur
vielmehr wollen sie eine regulierung
verhindern die strafrechtlich relevanten
kanälen ein ende bereiten könnte von
denen sie reichweite profitieren
es gibt immer zwei seiten einer medaille
netzwerke die telegramm ermöglichen eine
niedrigschwellige
selbstorganisierte kommunikation auch
die man in vielen teilen dieser welt
bitter angewiesen ist da sehen wir
derzeit in der ukraine und in russland
wo journalistinnen und oppositionelle
die auch bürgerinnen und bürger über
diesen dienst wichtige informationen
austauschen das informationsbedürfnis
ist groß residenz elend die der heute
morgen länger gesprochen hat erreicht
über telegramm 1,5 millionen menschen
zeitungen zitierten pendelns berichten
den eigenen eigenen kanal über den
russischen angriffskrieg und versorgen
die menschen mit lebenswichtigen
informationen die massendemonstrationen
in bella aus vor anderthalb jahren
wurden über die app organisiert als
keiner anderen kommune
kommunikationswege und mehr zur
verfügung standen man möchte vor scham
im boden versinken wenn sie sich mit den
verfolgten in autoritären regime ob
eines zu verstellen und die regulierung
von sozialen netzwerken und
wenn sie die regulierung von sozialen
netzwerken als schritt in die diktatur
anprangern wo bitte soll denn der
autoritären staat sein der sie verfolgt
weil sie ihre hanebüchenen verschwörungs
mieten eines unterjochten volkes kundtun
mit desinformationen aufwiegeln
menschenfeindliche ressentiments
bedienen und auf der grenze zur
verfassungswidrigkeit balancieren um es
klar zu sagen ein sperrung von telegramm
ist falsch das haben die ihn stets
betont auch die entfernung aus den app
stores wäre ein unverhältnismässiger
eingriff in die meinungsfreiheit
zudem würde es ja nur dazu führen dass
die akteure in andere netzwerke
abwandern das weiß auch die
bundesinnenminister in die an gestern
den aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus
vorgestellt hat das da genannt erster
stelle rechtsextreme netzwerke zu
zerschlagen stehen sie zu entwaffnen ist
die richtige schwerpunktsetzung denn
hier wurde so lange zugeschaut und ja
behörden müssen so aufgestellt sein dass
sie auch auf sozialen netzwerken nach
rechtsstaatlichen verfahren ermitteln
können
der messenger dienst als solcher ist ja
nicht gefährlich auch die motivation des
betreibers babbel darauf mag einem
hehren ziel dienen nämlich nutzerdaten
zu schützen wie er es nach eigenem
bekunden bereits vor der russischen
regierung getan hat wir würden uns aber
wünschen dass er dafür auch endlich den
verschlüsselungsstandard von telegramm
anhebt dennoch müssen oppositionelle die
verfolgt werden zusätzliche
schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen das
unternehmen muss erkennen dass der
dienst massiv genutzt wird um
rechtswidrige inhalte und informationen
zu verbreiten und dabei drohen fatale
auswirkungen wie wir es bei den
gezielten fehlinformationen im
kriegsgebiet in der ukraine sehen können
bei aller vorsicht vor überregulierung
in einem öffentlichen raum gibt es
regeln und an die müssen sich auch
anbieter von plattformen halten dabei
geht es bei telegramm ja nicht um den
eingriff in die 121 kommunikation oder
in geschlossenen chat gruppen es geht da
um öffentliche gruppen telegramm als
massenverbreitung instrument nutzen die
verschiedenen kommunikations teile von
telekom müssen daher getrennt betrachtet
werden
die radikalisierung einer minderheit die
in öffentlichen gruppen stattfindet
stellt eine bedrohung für die
gesellschaft und damit auch für unsere
demokratie da es ist gut dass es erste
anzeichen gibt das telegramm
verantwortung übernimmt so löschte der
dienst bereits vor jahren routinemäßig
propaganda des islamischen staates in
den vergangenen wochen wurden auf 64
deutschsprachige kanäle mit
extremistischen inhalten gesperrt aber
um willkür und unrechtmäßiges löschen zu
verhindern sowie transparenz und
widerspruchsmöglichkeiten zu sichern
genau dafür sind ja gesetzliche
regelungen notwendig und wenn wir vom
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz sprechen
ebenso ein überbleibsel aus der
vorgänger vorgängerregierung wir haben
unsere bedenken jahrelang geäußert
bezüglich der verfassungskonformität des
unionsrechts
datenschutzrechtliche bedenken aufgrund
der datenweitergabe an das bka unsere
änderungsanträge wurden damals alle
abgelehnt und nun befassen sich die
gerichte damit im koalitionsvertrag
haben wir uns auf eine gesamtbetrachtung
der problematik geeinigt dazu gehören
neben der überarbeitung des letzte geht
das digitale gewaltschutzgesetz die
login falle und die beseitigung
offenkundig bestehende durchsetzungs
defizite dieser nationalen regulierungen
müssen in den europarechtlichen rahmen
eingebettet sein und der dicke pitter
services eck befindet sich gerade im
trialog je nach verhandlungsergebnis
könnte telegramm dann auch unter dieses
gesetz fallen und ich begrüße dass sich
abzeichnet dass plattformen künftig
verpflichtet werden bei strafbaren
inhalten einzugreifen und deutlich
besser mit den behörden zu kooperieren
wir müssen zudem der grundsätzlichen
frage
uns der grundsätzlichen frage widmen wie
angesichts der fortschreitenden
fragmentierung von öffentlichkeit im
digitalen eine gemeinsame basis für den
sachorientierten demokratischen diskurs
gefunden werden kann dass eine nicht
regulierung auf dauer schwerwiegende
auswirkungen auf den
meinungsbildungsprozess haben zeigen
studien jeder zweite junge erwachsene
hat bereits digitale gewalt erfahren
nutzer innen ziehen deshalb aus
öffentlichen diskursen zurück ziehen
sich zurück hat kriminalität vergiftet
den demokratischen diskurs und spaltet
die gesellschaft es ist daher dringend
erforderlich öffentliche digitale
kommunikationsräume so zu gestalten dass
eine gemeinsam mit debatte gewährleistet
ist in dem sich die menschen ihre
meinung tatsächlich frei bilden können
unterschätzt unterschätzt wird in diesem
zusammenhang der aspekt der
monetarisierung von inhalten der
werbemarkt digitaler medien hat den
analogen seit 20 21 auf platz zwei
verdrängt dabei profitieren plattformen
ja von der reichweite polarisierender
inhalte ein geschäftsmodell das genauer
betrachtet werden muss denn es befördert
ja das auseinanderdriften der
gesellschaft und untergräbt genau diese
gemeinsame basis die öffentliche debatte
eine wichtige rolle spielt da der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk er wird
von den bürgerinnen also von uns allen
finanziert und ist von werbeeinnahmen
unabhängig dazu kommt die staatsferne
aufsicht durch gesellschaftliche gruppen
und übrigens jetzt auch sitzen auch afd
vertreterinnen in den rundfunk hätten
trotzdem wollen sie den öffentlich
rechtlichen sendern am liebsten in die
luft abdrehen diese logik erklärt sich
mir überhaupt nicht auf vielleicht damit
dass sie ein problem mit christ
kritischer berichterstattung haben die
tun nämlich eben job und setzen sich
kritisch mit politik und gesellschaft
auseinander
neben neben dem neuen aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus brauchen wir weitere
maßnahmen um die radikalisierung von
teilen der gesellschaft umzukehren das
gesetz gegen digitale gewalt und das
demokratie förderungsgesetz und
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement
aufklärung und aussteigerprogramme
nachhaltig zu fördern wir brauchen mehr
zivilgesellschaftliche gegenrede und
mehr journalistische einordnung von
desinformation das macht unsere
demokratie wehrhaft vielen dank
dass
sich die trödeln wir der
messenger-dienst telekom
so der willen der bundesregierung soll
mehr gegen mord aufrufe und hass in
seinem kann
machen telegramm machte in deutschland
ist
das bundeskriminalamt ist heute möglich
hat das vor wenigen tagen mitgeteilt
dass löschen regelung anregung des bka
umgesetzt worden sind beispielsweise den
kanälen des
verschwörungs ideologen hielt man in
deutschland gesperrt worden
sie sind alle hingegen frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren auch ich gehöre
zu jenen die sich die augen gerieben
haben als sie den antrag gelesen haben
ausgerechnet die fdp will sich mal
wieder allen ernstes als kämpferin für
die meinungsfreiheit aufspielen eine
partei die alles mit verachtung
betrachtet was nicht in ihr übles
weltbild passt ich bin lauter als sie
ich habe micro die anders denken denn
die andersdenkende am liebsten entsorgen
möchten die ganze wissenschaftszweige am
liebsten verbieten würde wer soll ihnen
so einen antrag ab nehmen sie fordern
auf die regulierung von telegramm zu
verzichten und ich habe den zitaten der
kollegen auch noch etwas hinzuzufügen
erst vor wenigen monaten ist eine
telegramm gruppe bekannt geworden in
bayern unter anderem bayerischer fd.com
auch hier im bundestag vertreten die
bizarre umsturz fantasien teilen ich
zitiere wir brauchen die totale
revolution
totale steht da an finden müsste man die
ganze politik oder denke dass wir ohne
bürgerkrieg aus dieser nummer nicht mehr
rauskommen werden und wie fast ihr ex
fraktionsmitglied johannes huber das
ganze zusammen in diesem in dieser
gruppe herrscht meinungsfreiheit meine
damen und herren genau dieses
verständnis von meinungsfreiheit ist es
das einen mordanschlag wir auf
regierungspräsidenten weiter brücke oder
den rechts terroristischen anschlag in
halle meiner stadt nicht nur toleriert
sondern begünstigt die afg aber leugnet
wider besseren wissens in ihrem antrag
diese zusammenhänge und das macht schon
einigermaßen fassungslos
sie verstehen
sie verstehen unter meinungsfreiheit die
freiheit zu hetzen unwahrheiten zu
verbreiten
zu gewalt und hass aufzurufen aber
meinungsfreiheit hat aus gutem grund wie
einige kollegen schon gesagt haben
grenzen und die erfordert eine
gesetzliche regulierung auch von
plattformen wie telegramm gerade dort
sind illegale inhalte viel zu lange
geduldet wurden ein problem das sich
verschärft hat ja ist doch richtig ab
ein problem das sich verschärft hat weil
telegramm geradezu heimat jener geworden
ist die sich anhand krude
verschwörungstheorien
nach rechts radikalisiert haben meine
damen und herren was wir aber in dieser
situation überhaupt nicht vergessen
dürfen sind eben auch debatten wie sie
zwischenzeitlich aus den reihen der
bundesregierung angestoßen worden sind
also forderungen danach wurde schon
erwähnt telegramm zu sperren oder eben
auch aus den app stores zu entfernen die
kollegin bayer von der spd da sehr klar
mit solchen maßnahmen begibt man sich
einerseits wie wir gerade sehen können
euch lust ungute gesellschaft
andererseits muss man zur kenntnis
nehmen welche rolle telegramm gerade
dabei spielt in kriegsgebieten der
ukraine und russland menschen mit
informationen zu erreichen oder eben
auch kontakte aufrechtzuerhalten
daran sieht man allein wie fragwürdig
solche maßnahmen sind schließlich und
grundsätzlich sei gesagt wenn ein chat
gruppen mit hunderten menschen
gewaltaufrufe geteilt werden dann ist
das eben kein technisches problem das
einer technischen lösung hat es geht
hier um grundrechte es geht um
grundwerte und es und vor allem um die
durchsetzung geltenden rechts
insofern ist es zu begrüßen dass es
offenbar kontakte mittlerweile zu
telegramm gibt und dort ein gewisser
kooperationswillen bei der löschung
strafbare inhalte signalisiert wurde
beziehungsweise sie haben es gesagt frau
ist bereits erfolgt ist darüber hinaus
müssen natürlich auch
strafverfolgungsbehörden solche
entwicklungen im auge behalten früher
reagieren aber vor allem müssen sie über
die notwendigen ressourcen verfügen
meine damen und herren die
meinungsfreiheit zu gewährleisten ist
keine leichte aufgabe aber keinesfalls
darf sie denen überlassen werden die
unter diesem vorwand nur die bahn frei
bekommen wollen für hetze und ungehalten
danke
für die linke
seit februar
gibt es kontakt zwischen
bundesregierung und vertretern der
konzernspitze von tele
[Applaus]
versorgt hat
sleep für die fdp fraktion dann haben
wir das ordentlich im protokoll noch mal
fand überhaupt kein problem frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen herzlichen dank der
ursprüngliche titel des antrages
gewährleistung der meinungsfreiheit auch
im internet hat mich neugierig gemacht
die antragstellerin als hüterin der
meinungsfreiheit eine partei die vom
verfassungsschutz als verdachtsfall
geführt werden darf schwer vorstellbar
und in der tat der text des antrages und
der vortrag vorhin endlauf die
überschrift es geht ihnen doch gar nicht
um meinungsfreiheit und es geht ihnen
auch nicht durch instagram telegramm
entschuldigung den antrag treibt doch
vielmehr ihre angst dass
rechtsstaatliche prinzipien auf einer
liebgewonnenen plattform endlich einzug
halten damit auch dort hass und hetze
rechts wirksam bekämpft werden können
und dort auch persönlichkeitsrechte
durchgesetzt werden können sie träumen
doch offenbar immer noch vom internet
als rechtsfreien raum kolleginnen
kollegen und das ist abwegig
die rechtlichen aussagen annahmen in dem
antrag sind abdecken spätestens mit
telekom.at ist klar und daran kann es
keinen zweifel geben diese plattform ist
ein soziales netzwerk im sinne des
netzwerk durchsetzung des gesetzes kein
zweifel und als rechtsstaatspartei
halten wir uns an geltendes recht und
das ist der unterschied zwischen
zwischen kunst und um liebhaberei und
das klar zu sagen um die partei ohne
gewinnerzielungsabsicht handelt es sich
bei elo kann gewiss nicht damit ist klar
es gibt die verpflichtung von telebärn
den zustellungsbevollmächtigten zu
benennen deswegen begrüße ich die
aktivitäten von bundesjustiz und
innenministerium dort weiter vorzugehen
und um es klar zu sagen das hat nichts
aber auch gar nichts mit zensur und
-überwachung zu tun es geht um nicht
mehr und nicht weniger als die
einhaltung geltenden rechts durch diese
plattform und dafür stehen hier
und zusätzlich es ist ein notwendiger
beitrag für den schutz auch der
persönlichkeitsrechte der nutzerinnen
und nutzer
denn in der tat es war nie und es wird
nie sein das internet ein rechtsfreier
raum und wer sich als plattform dem
schutz von meinungsfreiheit und dem
schutz von geistigem eigentum
verschreibt dem muss es doch erst recht
gerade bei diesen gründer ein anliegen
sein für persönlichkeitsrechte im
internet einzutreten deswegen muss klar
sein und deswegen fordere ich telekom
auf endlich geltendes recht in
deutschland einzuhalten endlich ist
einzuhalten es geht darum und nicht um
pauschale und um nichts anderes
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
unser grundgesetz gibt der
meinungsfreiheit zentralen raum das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat es mal so
schön formuliert es ist schlechthin
konstituierend für unsere demokratische
grundordnung und es schützt jede meinung
egal ob sie wertvoll und durchdacht oder
stumpf und unsinnig ist und die
kolleginnen von kollegen der afg seit
gesagt die letzten zwanzig sitzung habe
ich deutlich den eindruck dass das mit
den stumpf unsinnige meinung bei ihnen
ausgesprochen ausgeprägt ist
um das abschließend klar zu sagen bei
dieser koalition ist die
meinungsfreiheit in allerbesten händen
grundrechte und freiheit sind für uns
leid motiv und nicht verhandelbar und
dafür stehen wir gemeinsam
thorsten ihr lieb war das für die
fdp-fraktion hier mit seiner ersten rede
im bundestag
das wort hat der abgeordnete tobias
matthias bitter für die auktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte kollegen
man sieht es auch heute wieder
kommunikationskanäle die sich einen
leichten zugriff oder der moderation von
staatlichen stellen entziehen waren für
diese schon immer höchst verdächtig
sport und schnee gedichte beschäftigten
bereits im alten rom ganze
sondereinheiten kaum war der buchdruck
erfunden stand der büttel daneben und
ließ sich die entwürfe zeigen nun ist es
natürlich so dass man eine rasche
druckerei viel besser heimsuchen kann
als ein digitales unternehmen mit sitz
in dubai und dieses ganze ich zitiere
eine bekannte langzeit kanzlerin neuland
internet hat ohnehin die schreckliche
eigenschaft dass inzwischen jeder bürger
sich leisten kann inhalte äußerungen und
meinungen sehr leicht an einen offenen
empfängerkreis zu verbreiten keine
destillation durch wohltemperierte
sendeanstalten wie beim linearen tv
keine kasten bildung durch marktzutritt
schwellen wie bei den großen
zeitungsverlagen bitter bitter irgendwas
musste also getan werden verleumdung des
neuen mediums historisch gesehen immer
eine recht gute idee gewesen besser ist
natürlich den zugriff des staates erst
zu ermöglichen und zu erweitern das
deutsche netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz
ist damit quasi die neueste auflage des
druckerei beatles inklusive zuträger tun
und natürlich
natürlich frau martens und er liebt muss
jeder seine äußerungen ob offline oder
online an den allgemeinen gesetzen
messen lassen wenn der staat aber damit
anfängt unbestimmte tatbestände
einzuführen und damit das sagt bahre an
sich bereits im vorfeld filtern will
dann ist das einfach der abgedroschene
reflex der zensur
zitate wie das folgende sind einfach
arrogant und anmaßend diese app
verbreitet hat falschinformationen und
aufrufe zu gewalt gegen staatstragende
institutionen man müsse ein verbot in
betracht ziehen urheber davon übrigens
die russische medienaufsicht roßkopf
betreffend facebook beziehungsweise
instagram sie sehen
sie sehen also
genauso und sehr entlarvend wurde in
deutschland über telegramm geurteilt ein
dienst der übrigens keine
gewinnerzielungsabsicht im eigentlichen
sinn auch weist das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz fällt damit
eigentlich weg gut dass nebenbei an das
verleumden gedacht wurde aber wie kann
eine app schlecht für den erhalt der
demokratie sein wenn sie anderenorts und
autokratien offensichtlich erst die
grundelemente
demokratischen beisammenseins ermöglicht
nämlich die freie kommunikation die
selbstorganisation von mündigen mutigen
bürgern tut mir leid dem widerspruch
konnten sie heute auch nicht auflösen es
gab wieder nur billigste plattitüden von
ihnen in unsere richtung vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege sebastian
fiedler zu seiner ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag für die spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren wenn man
weiterhin in der rednerliste ist dann
ist die gefahr groß dass alle
demokratischen parteien sich im hause
hier relativ einig sind und auf
dieselben zitate gestoßen sind auf die
ich in der regierung vorher auch schon
gestoßen bin deswegen lassen nämlich
zunächst mal sagen dass ich den antrag
der afg eigentlich ganz gut finde weil
er wie unter einem brennglas sozusagen
idealtypisch für die afg und für deren
handeln ist und das macht ihn glaube ich
so besonders gut und es gibt mir die
gelegenheit sozusagen zu zwei aspekten
vielleicht einfach noch kurz zu ergänzen
auf der einen seite zu telegramm selbst
und auf der anderen seite zu meiner
persönlichen meinung zur afd in diesem
zusammenhang und zur bedeutung des
antrages was tut element noch nicht
erwähnt worden ist und ich habe mir
gestern und heute noch einmal die mühe
gemacht es ist viel darüber geredet
worden dass es neben den unmittelbaren
kommunikationskanälen also der messenger
funktion natürlich plattform funktionen
gibt die unstreitig sind die in vielen
passagen des antrages schlicht ignoriert
oder abgestritten werden es gibt auch
plattformen die eine markt dort form für
illegale inhalte sind sie finden also
rauschgifte unterschiedlicher art und
weise sie können sich heroin crystal
meth sie können sich das doch bildern
und videos demonstrieren lassen sie
können waffen bestellen sie finden
geldwäsche dienstleistungen dass wir
dort angeboten wie viel das jeweils
kostet sie können sich falschgeld
bestellen also es gibt durchaus eine
illegale markt plattform dort die über
die anderen fragen noch hinaus das heißt
über die fragen hass und hetze über nord
rogan im netz die auch gegen viele von
uns noch nach wie vor dort existenz sein
dürften natürlich ein problem sind und
ehrlich gesagt nur darum geht es hier
nur darum geht es bei dem bemühen der
innenministerin und des justizminister
und das natürlich auch richtig so in
einem rechtsstaat und
es kann natürlich auch nur außer zweifel
stehen das sind natürlich dann wenn man
dann einen solchen betreiber einer
solchen plattform gar nicht erreicht
dass man entsprechend druck ausgeübt und
dass so worte die compliance bezogen auf
diejenigen die diese app bereit stellen
natürlich eine rolle spielen dass man
sich dafür an diejenige richtet um
überhaupt kontakte zu nehmen und ich
finde es außerordentlich gut und
begrüßenswert dass es der
bundesregierung jetzt gelungen ist
überhaupt diese schritte in die wege zu
leiten
absatz jetzt können sie fragen was hat
das alles mit meinungsfreiheit zu tun
nichts gar nichts für meinungsfreiheit
hat es nur deswegen etwas zu tun weil es
einen erzählstrang der afd bedient und
ausgerechnet der afg ich bin neu im
deutschen bundestag und habe das aus der
ferne und von den monitoren bisher
vergleichen vergleichen können und haben
jetzt hier jeden tag erlebt dass
wirklich die afd die grenzen des artikel
5 aber bis zum letzten ende tag für tag
auslotet in nahezu jeder einzelnen rede
versucht immer wieder die grenzen noch
ein stück weit zu verschieben und
auszuloten also dass ausgerechnet sie
sich über die grenzen der
meinungsfreiheit zu beklagen ist
geradezu grotesk
das steht im artikel 5 da steht auch
foto grenzen freiheit sind und das ist
auch gut und richtig so und auf der
anderen seite leben wir historisch in
einer zeit in der die individuen noch
nie so viele möglichkeiten hatten sich
individuell in ihrer meinung zu äußern
und das allemal im digitalen raum und
das ist auch gut und richtig so und
jetzt kommen allerdings zwei dinge
zueinander
meine meinung ist nämlich und da gehe
ich noch weiter als die offizielle
behörde dass es sich bei der afg um eine
rechtsextreme partei antritt und genau
dieser umstand
hat direkt damit zu können warum die
bundesinnenminister richtigerweise sagt
dass der rechtsextremismus die größte
gefahr für unseren demokratischen
rechtsstaat ist und da geht es nicht um
die zahlen alleine die in irgendwelchen
statistiken stehen bei denen sich die
afg hier und da im art von cherry
picking versucht an einzelnen zahlen zu
bedienen es geht darum und das hat der
generalbundesanwalt auf einer
veranstaltung die ich noch als
vorsitzender des bund deutscher
kriminalbeamter moderieren durfte sehr
treffend formuliert der unterschied zu
anderen extremisten ist dass die gefahr
hier aus dem inneren des staates droht
ich kann mich nicht erinnern dass wir in
einem landesparlament eine islamistische
partei sitzen haben ich kann mich nicht
erinnern dass wir in behörden die das
gewaltmonopol des staates verkörpern
polizei soldaten dass wir dort
islamistische probleme haben da kann ich
mich schlechterdings nicht erinnern
sondern das aushöhlen sozusagen mit
einem rechtsextremen trojanischen pferd
des staates von innen das ist die größte
gefahr die diese demokratie zu
überwältigen
und das hat norbert lammert einmal ganz
gut formuliert ich bin darauf gestoßen
hätten bei einer veranstaltung ganz gut
formuliert und er hat gesagt die
demokratie und insbesondere eine gut
funktionierende demokratie ist gegen das
wahlverhalten der bürgerinnen und bürger
nicht gefällt und ich ergänze das ist
auch gut so das problem ist nur wenn
dieses wahlverhalten durch manipulierte
informationen befeuert wird in
irgendwelchen kanälen die stube
erzählungen verschwörungs extremisten
sich mit rechtsextremisten haben dann
entsteht daraus diese sehr sehr
problematische komplott was der
demokratie wirklich gefährlich sein kann
und deswegen der gute rat an alle die
sich informieren wollen tun sie das bei
professionellen journalistischen
journalisten die haben das gelernt die
überprüfen den wert einer information
informieren sie sich also breit und
nicht nur und ausschließlich in sozialen
medien dass der appell am ende
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
wie sagt sogar fitter für die spd
fraktion in seiner ersten rede im
bundestag er direkt gewählt im nordrhein
westfalen den wahlkreis mülheim essen
und war bis 2021 übrigens er hat es nur
der rede kurz angesprochen
bundesvorsitzender des bundes deutscher
kriminalbeamter
nächste herr peter pohl volker ullrich
für die cdu csu fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren der antrag der afg
lautet keine zensur von telegramm
meinungsfreiheit
schützen dieser antragstext zeigt auf
die eigentliche intention der afg
nämlich die erzählung zu bedienen
meinungsfreiheit sei in unserem land
nicht mehr in dem umfang gegeben und sie
seien in gefahr aber diese erzählung ist
falsch und sie an einen anderen
hintergrund sie wollen damit das
vertrauen in die institutionen unseres
staates erschüttern und auf diesem
erschütterten vertrauen ihre eigene
agenda aufsetzen die diesen staat
beseitigen oder zumindest verändern
möchte und das dürfen und werden wir
ihnen nicht durchgehen
meinungsfreiheit ist gefährdet übrigens
in russland wenn die rede über krieg mit
bis zu 15 jahren haft bestraft werden
kann aber dazu schweigen sie und diese
distanzlosigkeit fällt auf sie zurück
die meinungsfreiheit ist elementar für
den freiheitlich demokratischen
rechtsstaat sie ist auch sehr weitgehend
gar keine frage aber die aufrufe zum
mord und gewalt
beleidigungen
holocaust relativierungen an holocaust
leugnungen das anbieten von
kinderpornografie oder von drogen
unterfeld nicht der meinungsfreiheit
sondern sind straftaten die mit der
gesamten härte des rechtsstaats
aufgeklärt und verfolgt werden müssen
egal wo sie passieren
das netz durch setzte das gesetz schützt
übrigens die freie und offene
gesellschaft kollegin uns bestärken sie
eine frage oder
vielen dank dr ulrich kohli röhrig sie
sprachen eben sehr pauschal von der
meinungsfreiheit und der freiheit des
geistes und der meinung ist ihnen
bekannt sollten ja auch noch in der
forschung und kontakt zu universitäten
haben dass ihnen durchaus junge anwärter
aber auch professoren sagen durchaus
strittigen themen gebieten das ist heute
schon die politische die für die
wissenschaftliche karriere behindern
oder zerstören kann an universitäten die
falschen fragen zu stellen b vielleicht
auch die falsche meinung aus unserer
sicht zu äußern dass tatsächlich
professor in einem vier-augen-gespräch
schon darlegen in bestimmten
themengebieten und die gehen sogar
wirtschaftswissenschaften an die können
das strittige klima dass das strittige
thema der klimapolitik angehen ist es
heute schon für viele professoren
durchaus überlegenswert das zu häusern
das zu publizieren was sie eigentlich in
ihrem forschungsgebiet main ist ihnen
das bekannt wollen sie das leugnen da
hätte ich gerne mal ihre meinung zu
gehört
herr kollege sie bestätigen mit ihrer
einlassung meine eingangs formulierte
these nämlich dass das mangelt dass sie
versuchen
für mangelndes vertrauen in die
institutionen zu schärfen und diese
erzählungen die meinungsfreiheit
gefährdet immer und immer wieder sagen
weil es in ihrer agenda passt wer eine
abseitige meinung äußert darf diese
äußern aber er hat kein recht auf
widerspruchsfreiheit meinungen
meinungen die abseitig sind die müssen
auch der deal muss man entgegnen doch
offenen widerspruch und das gehört zum
diskurs alternde gesellschaft dazu sie
haben keinen anspruch darauf dass ihre
meinung als die mahnung anerkannt wird
die sie gerne hätten sondern entscheiden
ist das eine offene gesellschaft auch
den diskurs 14 und um nichts anderes
geht es
die große frage ist ob
das netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz auch
auf telegramm anwendbar ist oder nicht
im text das lässt für das
durchsetzungsvermögen
davon nicht betroffen ist so weit so gut
der punkt ist aber dass sich auf
telegramm mittlerweile gruppen gebildet
haben die bis zu
200.000 teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
haben und diesen gruppen wird geteilt
und kommentiert und diese gruppen haben
eindeutig den charakter eines sozialen
netzwerkes weil hier meinung dargestellt
kommentiert und verbreitet wird und
deswegen gilt ganz klar auch telegramm
kann sich den deutschen gesetzen nicht
entziehen sie brauchen einen
zustellungsbevollmächtigten und sie
müssen sich an die deutsche
rechtsordnung halten das
bundesjustizminister stützung wenn es
darum geht die elementaren
voraussetzungen das netzwerk
durchsetzung selbst dass auch
einzuhalten
nun wenn man diesen antrag der afg liest
dann sprechen sie im antragstext auch
über
islamistischen terror und über
terroristen die sich über das netzwerk
telegramm ausgetauscht haben es zu
treffen zum beispiel der attentäter vom
breitscheidplatz
allerdings hat auch der attentäter von
halle
in gruppen die den white spaces
zugeordnet sind
seine tat verbreitet ist das video
verbreitet worden
um mich hat es sehr nachdenklich gemacht
dass sie in einem antrag zur telekom
wozu telegramm über islamistischen
terror gesprochen haben aber zu den
auswüchsen der rechtsextremen bedrohung
vollständig geschwiegen haben das ist
nicht naiv das ist unverzeihlich weil es
damit indirekt auch billigen meine damen
und herren es
ist nicht das netzwerk selbst
das im mittelpunkt der debatte steht
zwar das netzwerk nicht die meinungen
die dort gepostet werden
selbst verursacht sondern es sind
menschen und nutzer die das posten und
deswegen muss der ansatz sein dass wir
diejenigen die gegen die strafgesetze
verstoßen dass die zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden dass aber der diskurs
raum offen bleiben muss aber es fängt
nicht nur einer frage an wie wir
soziale medien und netzwerke regulieren
müssen sondern auch eine frage von die
radikalisierung in der gesellschaft
selber warum radikalisieren sich
menschen warum ist man bereit auf einen
mord aufruf zu starten über diese fragen
müssen uns auch in der gesellschaft
unterhalten es geht auch um die frage
wie wir filter blasen verhindern können
emotionen und hast es geht um einen
angstfreien diskurs um rede und
gegenrede
es geht um die verwirklichung von
demokratie und von teilhabe aber es geht
nicht darum wie sie geschrieben haben
meinung zu verhindern das ist falsch und
dem treten wir entgegen deswegen lehnen
wir ihren antrag ab
[Applaus]
volker ullrich war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion er das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz verpflichtet
strafrechtlich relevante inhalte zu
löschen und muss sie seit dem ersten
februar
2022 auch dem bundeskriminalamt melden
strittig ist unter einigen juristen ob
telekom unter dieses gesetz fällt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die meinungsfreiheit ist ein elementares
grundrecht ein grundrecht das geschützt
werden ist und ich kann ihnen versichern
dieses grundrecht diese meinungsfreiheit
die ist bei dieser koalition in guten
händen und das gerade eine partei die
vor einer woche zum rechtsextremen
verdachtsfall erklärt wurde jetzt mit
einem antrag die fahne der
meinungsfreiheit nach oben hängt dass es
an dreistigkeit nicht mehr zu überbieten
und
liebe kollegen lassen wir uns bei dieser
debatte auch bitte nichts sand in die
augen streuen da fd geht es in wahrheit
nämlich überhaupt gar nicht um telegramm
geht es darum dass sie ihre felle
davonschwimmen sieht geht es darum dass
sie ganz offensichtlich weiß dass in
denselben gruppen in denen zum mord von
politikern aufgerufen wird in denen die
krudesten verschwörungstheorien
verbreitet werden dass dort auch
wahlaufrufe für die afg erfolgen und
dann auch noch auf basis des artikel 5
grundgesetz zu argumentieren es schamlos
ein hinweis an die kollegen der afg
nämlich auf artikel 23 absatz artikel
absatz 2 des artikel 5 grundgesetz auf
meinungsfreiheit hat seine grenzen und
zwar dort wo hass und hetze wo rassismus
oder antisemitismus sowie aufrufe zum
mord begangen werden auch wenn sie jetzt
nicht nur ein möchten auch wenn sie da
immer wieder die augen zu schließen es
ist richtig dass der rechtsstaat hier
handelt
aber kommen wir zum antrag selbst und
der auf dem bad das die afg fraktion
wieder das rechtliche noch das
technische verständnis zur einordnung
von telekom hat und ich möchte das auch
noch einmal verdeutlichen telegramm kann
man nicht singulär betrachten telegramm
ist ein hybride ein hybrides tool eine
hybride plattform denn einerseits und
das auch noch mal klar zu machen ist es
ein verschlüsselter messenger dienst auf
der anderen seite stellt er aber eben
auch in bezug auf die offenen gruppen
eine plattform dar und ich möchte dass
an der stelle auch noch mal betonen es
geht und ging der koalition niemals
darum die persönliche kommunikation
einzelner personen zu verhindern und
sogar netzsperren zu verhängen zumal
netzsperren das möchte ich als digital
politiker gesagt haben immer der falsche
weg sind und auch nicht funktionieren
bald telegramm aber eben kein
ausschließlicher messenger ist sondern
eben auch eine plattform muss eben auch
dort natürlich gegen hass vorgegangen
werden und was mir ebenfalls fehlt in
ihrem antrag ist und das verwundert
nicht dass wir endlich anfangen
aufzuhören die digitale welt im
nationalen grenzen zu denken verwundert
bei ihnen nicht aber genau das ist zum
glück aktuell in planung denn der
zukünftige digital services sector
d'isere wird eben diesen einheitlichen
rechtsrahmen schaffen auf europäischer
ebene der auch um das sei an der stelle
auch explizit gesagt die vorhandenen
schwächen das netz die die obsolet
machen und ich möchte zum abschluss auch
noch einmal verdeutlichen dass auch ich
bauchschmerzen habe dass bei einem
solchen antrag der afg trotz der
rassistisch motivierten
anschläge in hannover trotz des mordes
an walter lübke trotz des
antisemitischen rassistischen anschlags
in halle ausschließlich der
islamistische terrorismus angesprochen
wird eine selbst offenbarung
sondersgleichen im antrag der eigentlich
gar nicht wert ist dass wir ihnen
diskutieren dass wir ihn heute
diskutieren ist der beweis dafür dass
wir meinungsfreiheit in diesem land
haben herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
sagen sie
ich bitte sie sich einer
parlamentarischen ausdrucksweise zu
befleißigen
[Musik]
das wort hat der kollege marc
henrichmann für die cdu/csu funzel
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das vierte wort im antrag der
afg ist glaub ich russland und man
braucht nicht lange um einen unternehmer
einen gründer von telegrammen nämlich zu
führen und als fast heiligen mit hehren
absichten ansätzen zu bezeichnen und ich
habe mich sehr geschämt dass muss ich
lange sagen als die sogenannten von den
medien so bezeichneten russland
connections der spd verhindert haben
dass wir uns viel früher an die seite
der ukraine gestellt haben aber wenn ich
jetzt auf dem höhepunkt der eskalation
diese russland feierlichkeiten im afg
antrag wieder lese dann wird mir
schlecht das ist billige propaganda und
provokation aber auch inhaltlich ist der
antrag sei vieles ist gesagt ich möchte
nur anführen dass beispielsweise in
kilogramm gruppen auch die täter die die
polizisten in rheinland-pfalz erschossen
haben sich haben feiern lassen und auch
das bka sagt auch das wurde angesprochen
das kilogramm ein beliebter weg sei mit
drogen zu handeln
ob das jetzt die erklärung ist für den
dürftigen inhalt und auch das abfeuern
von pilgram science chf dem möchte ich
nur spekulieren aber
finde ich schon lege heinrich mann
gestatten sie eine frage oder bewahrung
der abgeordneten cota gerne
danke dass sie die frage zu lassen sie
haben behauptet dass in unseren anderer
russland ab gefeiert wird und haben sich
sehr abfällig über klitschko geäußert
ist ihnen bewusst dass dieser mann
russland verlassen musste weil er von
der russischen regierung unter druck
gesetzt worden ist die daten
herauszugeben weil er so unter druck
gesetzt worden ist als er um sein leben
fürchten musste und deswegen hat er
mittlerweile auch eine andere
staatsangehörigkeit und taucht unter
weil er um sein leben fürchten musste
weil er von russland und von putin weg
laufen musste und sie unterstellen mir
ich hätte im antrag den gelobt und
beleidigen diesem mann der für die
freiheit gekämpft hat wie kein anders
kann als leiter ist und sein antrag
nicht gelesen oder nicht verstanden
haben ja kollege
[Applaus]
ich gebe zu es hat schwer gefallen ihnen
zu lesen und ihn auch zu verstehen aber
ich habe es tatsächlich getan und ist
auch in russland relativ früh auf und
sie wissen auch das telegramm und die
russische regierung sich relativ schnell
zeit mal wieder angenähert haben und
insofern wollen sie hat sich ernsthaft
bestreiten ihre affinität zur russischen
regierung unter kanzler ausweiten die
sind nach syrien gefahren teile ihrer
fraktion assad gefeuert dass sie putin
hofieren war jeder gelegenheit ist
glaube ich auch jedem bekannt das ist
schwach und ich finde ehrlicherweise
wenn sie schreiben es ist privatsache
der erwachsenen nutzer von kino wir
haben auch das normal als ergänzung
finde ich sie schon ziemlich schräg was
in ihrem ansatz in dem antrag hier
verbreitet wird also deswegen brauchen
wir glaube ich war ja russland
affinitäten nicht weiter zu sprechen
[Applaus]
ist in der tat ein kommunikationsweg und
ist so ein bisschen vielleicht analog
verglichen die dorfkneipe die persönlich
das problem ist sondern der stammtisch
an dem vielleicht gepöbelt beschimpft
und beleidigt wird da muss angesetzt
werden ich habe selber im wahlkreis eine
kommune die beispielsweise darüber
arbeit berichtet und das mit gutem
gewissen und auch mit guten absichten
tut und deswegen ist es richtig ja die
meinungsfreiheit hochzuhalten und zu
schützen aber da muss eben auch abwägung
her wir sind in einem rechtsstaat und da
gelten regeln und auch die würde des
einzelnen des menschen ist eben
abzuwägen und in sachen dieses
staatlichen schutz anspruches muss man
so deutlich sagen ist die ampel aber ein
totalausfall und ganz ehrlich habe ich
jetzt noch bei keiner rede in einem
redebeitrag gehört wie wir die probleme
die alle zu treffen beschreiben über
diese probleme angehen und es ist ja so
die ampel ist hier als tiger gestartet
im dezember noch herr buschmann frau
feser entschlossenes vorgehen propagiert
bis hin zum verbot und zur abschaltung
von telegramm der großstadt im ausschuss
für die spd am 12 erst noch gesagt das
netz dg hätte viel schärfer ausfallen
müssen und dann hat man aber offenbar
den anpacker nicht gefunden und hat in
der tat nach europa league ob dsl
digital service act angesprochen
position des rates und des europäischen
parlamentes bleiben in wichtigen punkten
deutlich hinter dem netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz zurück so der
staatssekretär der spd am 26
und auf die frage was man denn tut um
dieses dsl das paket auf den richtigen
weg zu bringen ist man jede antwort
schuldig geblieben die ampel hat
keinerlei idee was sie tun möchte oder
am 27 erster der spiegel berichtet frau
faeser forderte drastische maßnahmen
jetzt rudert sie zurück und am vierten 2
divac jubelmeldung seien unangemessen
feser freut sich wie bolle zitat dass
sich kilogramm auf ein gespräch mit ihr
ein lässt und das gespräch nicht etwa
weil es eine schlagkräftige
bundesregierung in deutschland gibt
sondern bei google eine e mail adresse
an die ampel anteil an vw auf mehr
weitergeleitet hatten überhaupt mal
kontakt zur telegramm herzustellen und
dieses ganze weichgespülte ohne ansatz
wo uns gleichzeitig experten sagen dass
kilogramm nur ein minimalprogramm angeht
was die löschung von hate speech angeht
dass die afg völlig lost ist und anstand
und respekt in der diskussion hier auch
vermissen lässt wurde deutlich aber
lieber bundesregierung sie sind jetzt
100 tage im amt ich glaube insbesondere
auch die betroffenen familien der
ermordeten polizisten und andere von
hate speech hass und hetze betroffenen
personen können erwarten dass sie ihren
job machen und es reicht nicht in
sonntagsreden zu fordern dass hass und
hetze entschieden bekämpft werden wenn
sie an der stelle nicht endlich konkret
werden und uns sagen was sie vorhaben um
das zu unterbinden bislang habe ich hier
nichts gehört den antrag der alt
und lebte
seitdem hat er ihr auch angesprochen
das eu-parlament hat ja dieses gesetz
auf den weg gebracht das einigen als
historisch gilt weltweit wird nämlich
zum ersten mal persönlich
gesetzgeber die grundrechte
bürgerinnen von
facebook und co durchzusetzen ob das
wirklich gelingt und der ganz große wurf
das 40 zeigen müssen die
gesetzgebung
und die bindung zwischen dem wesen der
situation wenn es im fusion nacken
antrag beschließen der fordert in
freibädern sollen keine regeln und
gesetze mehr gelten oder in stuttgart
sollen keine regeln und gesetze mehr
gelten das klingt doch sehr absurd aber
es ist in etwa das was die afg heute in
ihrem antrag fordert nur eben für den
messenger-dienst telekom telegramm ist
erstmal ein raum in dem sich menschen
begegnen wie einem freibad oder in
stuttgart nur eben digital ich glaube
die meisten menschen sind gut freundlich
und halten sich an regeln ihretwegen
bräuchte man wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
viele regeln aber wer öfter mal in
stuttgarter der im freibad war trifft
auch dort menschen mit schlechten
absichten und solche menschen sind
natürlich auch auf telegramm und für
solche fälle brauchen wir regeln
vielleicht gibt es auch afd abgeordnete
die regeln auf telegramm sinnvoll finden
aber mit ihrem antrag würde die fds
unmöglich machen dass wir als
gesellschaft als staat diese regeln
durchsetzen können und regeln die wir
nicht durchsetzen können sind keine
regeln und dann orten ohne regeln kann
jeder machen was er will wohl jeder
machen kann was er will gibt es
schließlich keine freiheit mehr da papa
nennt das das freiheits paradoxon weil
in so einer welt die starken die
schwachen tyrannisieren und die nicht
frei sein können davon schreibt in
seinem buch die offene gesellschaft und
ihre feinde die feinde unserer offenen
gesellschaft stehen nicht nur modell für
einen buchtitel sie sitzen auch in
diesem parlament sie haben heute einen
antrag gestellt mit dem sie uns ein
stück weit unserer freiheit berauben
wollen ein zweites ziel dieses antrags
mag sein den zusammenhalt in der eigenen
anhängerschaft den rechtsextremen
gruppen und querdenker strömt zu stärken
diese gruppen funktionieren nur seinem
feindbild und wenn sie sich selber als
opfer sehen können die afg soll dieser
niederträchtige feind unter anderem der
staat sein der start der gegen den
willen ihrer anhänger regeln auf
telegramm durch sitzt schauen wir dass
uns an wie es wirklich ist ja auch
telegramm mit einem freund hin und her
schreibt genießt das fernmeldegeheimnis
hier dürfte auch die afg zufrieden sein
selbst wenn sie es vielleicht nicht
zugibt anders ist es bei den
öffentlichen telegramm kanälen mit
vielen nutzerinnen und nutzer diese
kanäle müssen wir als soziales netzwerk
begreifen als öffentliche kommunikation
denn was den zieht denn sonst auf
öffentlichen telegramm kanälen muss weil
sie ein soziales netzwerk sind dann auch
das netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz
anwendbar sein das bedeutet dann der
betreiber von telegram hat pflichten er
braucht unter anderem ein
beschwerdemanagement er muss
vierteljährliche bericht man muss
öffentlich offensichtlich rechtswidrige
inhalte mischen inzwischen muster
betreiber dem bundeskriminalamt auch
melden wenn der verdacht auf
beispielsweise volksverhetzung vorliegen
das bietet dem staat die möglichkeiten
seine gesetze durchzusetzen
das stört telegramm und das stört die
afg aus jeweils unterschiedlichen
gründen ich kann telegramm einiges
abgewinnen die demokratischen opposition
in belarus oder dem iran organisieren
sich dort und sowieso nutzen millionen
ganz normale menschen jeden tag diesen
dienst doch auch ich nehme wahr dort
organisieren sich nicht nur yoga treff
sondern auch kriminelle gruppen
organisierte hetzer und verschwörer
verstoßen sie gegen unsere gesetze
müssen wie ihre machenschaften auch auf
telegram verbieten können darum brauchen
wir das netzwerk durch besetzungs gesetz
und wir halten es bei öffentlichen
telegram canyon auch verein schließlich
auf europäischer ebene müssen wir jetzt
mit dem digital services act
vergleichbare regeln eu weit durchsetzen
besonders wichtig ist uns plattform vita
rom sollen auch straftaten gegen die
demokratie melden müssen zumindest
müssen wir das auf nationaler ebene in
deutschland so regeln können wir wollen
überall aus leidvoller erfahrung unsere
demokratie wehrhaft verteidigen können
für den triumph des bösen reicht es wenn
die guten nichts tun hat edmund burke
immer gesagt mit diesem antrag wie die
afg nicht nur dass wir nichts tun die
afb will dass wir nichts tun können und
das wäre fatal
die welt lässt sich sicherlich nicht in
sauber in gut und böse einteilen aber
eine sache ist klar diejenigen die gegen
juden gegen muslime oder gegen andere
mitmenschen hetzen den sitzt unser
rechtsstaat auf der pelle für sie dafür
kein platz geben nicht bei uns nicht in
stuttgart nicht im freibad nicht auf
telegramm und wer sich schützend vor
diese hetze erstellt verdienen sollte
auch nicht platz sein in unserem
parlament nie wieder vielen dank
[Applaus]
robbie in misano schwarzes für die
spd-fraktion und ihn fragt jetzt hier
einer der insgesamt vier fraktionslosen
abgeordneten geht derzeit im deutschen
bundestag sitzen matthias hilfrich frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren wir zum mord aufruft andere
beleidigt oder illegales material
verbreitet muss einem strafverfahren
zugeführt werden darüber kann es in
einem rechtsstaat keine diskussion geben
wenn aber das establishment der
bundesrepublik sie also vom regulierung
von telegramm und vom kampf gegen hass
und hetze was auch immer das sein mag
sprechen dann geht es um mehr als um
strafverfolgung dann geht es ihnen um
die bekämpfung freiheitlicher
informationsgewinnung und die
betonierung ihrer eigenen macht wenn
sich der iranische wenn sich iranischen
mullahs und der nrw-verfassungsschutz
einig sind sollten sie als selbst dante
demokraten in diesem hause aufhorchen
will man im iran den messenger dienst
für regimekritische unruhen
verantwortlich macht bei denen frauen
sich über die gesetzliche pflicht das
kopftuch zu tragen hinwegsetzen fürchtet
man zum beispiel bei uns in düsseldorf
bei den schlapphüten auf oppositionellen
jagd ich zitiere die zentrale
kommunikationsplattform zur verbreitung
ungefilterter ideologischer inhalte
sowie zur mobilisierung von
protestveranstaltungen frau dr martens
hat es ja auch hat sich ein grab
verknappt hat sie sagt er sie fürchtet
ein anwachsen von oppositionellen
bewegungen in deutschland durch
telegramm und deshalb so telegramm
bekämpft werden ob iran oder berlin
aller orts scheinen die herrschenden die
vernetzung oppositioneller kreise den
zugang zu ungefilterten informationen
und demokratische
protestbewegungen zu fürchten ihr ziel
ist die zensur die sie in blumige worte
des linksliberal ismus hüllen das tier
ist die rückgewinnung von verloren
gegangenen diskurs monopolen und auch
die ampel regierung spürt dass es in
deutschland dem regierungskritischen
lager dank entsprechender messenger
dienste möglich geworden ist an den
medialen gatekeeper den großen
zeitungshäusern und dem staatsfunk
vorbei informationen und interpretation
der politischen wirklichkeit
auszutauschen vorbei ist die zeit beim
establishment wo man sich zurücklehnen
konnte darauf die kondition kraft von
zdf und spiegel vertrauen durfte was wir
nun erleben ist nichts anderes als die
autoritäre versuchung der etablierten
verlorene zustimmung zum eigene tun mit
der ausweitung von zwangsmitteln wie dem
netzwerk durchsetzung des gesetzes zu
kompensieren das wird man ihnen nicht
durchgehen lassen vielen dank
das wort hat der kollege manuel
verliehen für die fdp wird
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geschätzten kolleginnen und kollegen der
vorliegende antrag der afg ist erneut
kein ernsthafter debattenbeitrag für
dieses land und zu diesem thema und ich
muss ihnen ehrlich sagen als ich ihren
antrag die woche dann endlich gesehen
habe schoss es mir durch den kopf das
ist ein bisschen wie fußpilz man will es
eigentlich nicht sehen aber man muss
sich damit beschäftigen
und deswegen werde ich das jetzt auch
gerne tun
sie haben von der materie die sie darin
erwähnen wenn man es liest keine ahnung
und zweitens sie schieben wohlklingende
phasen vor ihre eigenen absichten ich
will nicht wiederholen was viele redner
hier gesagt haben ich will auch nicht
zitieren was die ihnen nahestehen oder
sie schon sagen weil ich finde dafür
muss ich auch hier keine plattform geben
ich will aber ein paar technische
bemerkungen und auch einschätzungen
machen die zwei punkte betreffen erstens
es ist entweder kalkül oder wirklich
unkenntnis wie sie die funktionsweise
von teleplan beschreiben sie tun so als
ob es dort grundsätzlich nur um
vertrauliche kommunikation und
meinungsfreiheit geht und sie wissen
genau dass es nicht so ist und sie
wollen einfach auch nicht sehen und
verstehen das telegramm mehrere
funktionen hat nämlich eine vertrauliche
verschlüsselte kommunikation und einen
offenen teil der mehr einer website im
besten fall eines sozialen netzwerkes
entspricht jeder kann damit lesen was
dort veröffentlicht wird und
selbstverständlich gilt öffentlich
zugängliche dokumente und meinungen und
schriften und medien jeder art dann auch
den deutschen und dem europäischen recht
das ist eine selbstverständlichkeit und
sie wollen diese hybride plattformen ich
anerkennen sie zünden aber auch
nebelkerzen indem sie im text permanent
von verschlüsselung oder von
vertraulicher kommunikation sprechen
dort beispiele anführen die aber auch
gar nicht zutreffend sind es geht
nämlich in dem was kommuniziert wurde
den letzten wochen ausschließlich um den
öffentlichen teil ausschließlich und
natürlich kann man öffentliche teile wie
funktionieren wie ein soziales netzwerk
nach dem deutschen netz dg regulieren
ich bin kein freund dessen ich habe das
oft gesagt und wir haben auch in der
koalition vereinbart dass wir denen die
es auf europäischer ebene abwarten und
dann eine umsetzung das netz tg im
nationalen recht entsprechend machen und
dem so wie es vereinbart haben werden
wir auch folgen und es ist auch richtig
so aber ihr antrag da geht es doch ihnen
doch eigentlich etwas ganz anderes sie
wollen die veröffentlichungsplattform
die ihnen unter vermeintlichen eins zu
eins kommunikation zur verfügung stehen
weiter offen halten damit menschen wie
attila hildmann deren kanäle jetzt
beschlossen sind oder andere nicht
reguliert werden und das ist unlauter
und das ist nicht nur unlauter ist
einfach sachlich falsch und eigentlich
müssten sie es selbst einsehen und
deswegen werden wir uns natürlich mit
ihrem antrag wohlwollend beschäftigen so
wie es einleitend erwähnt habe und am
ende werden wir dementsprechend auch
behandeln aber vielleicht denken sie
meine zukunft nach ob sie einen
sinnvollen beitrag zu solchen fragen in
zukunft leisten herzlichen dank
war das gegnerische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion
nächste rednerin hier der aussprache zu
dem antrag der fdp-fraktion sie ist die
abgeordnete katharina dos santos
aber für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen zuerst
möchte ich nochmal nachdem wir ja viel
gehört haben eins deutlich sagen
telegramm ist kein opfer das netz tg das
netz beschränkt die verbreitung von
strafrechtlichen inhalten wie die planen
von straftaten pass hetze bedrohungen
oder sexuelle gewalt gegen kinder
unabhängig von einem möglichen
anwendungsbereich ist das netz ag mit
dem ziel verabschiedet worden
rechtsverletzungen möglichst schnell zu
ahnden und zehn gramm hat hier keine
herausgehobene stellung im gegenteil
weil telegramm gleich behandelt wird mit
anderen diensten hat es sich genauso an
recht und gesetz zu halten denn täter
müssen belangt werden können und zwar
egal auf welcher plattform egal in der
analogen oder in der digitalen welt
und wir sprechen den leider nicht von
rein theoretischen annahmen dass soziale
netzwerke und dienste eine besondere
rolle spielen der antrag der fdp
suggeriert es gäbe keinerlei
zusammenhang zwischen ich zitiere
grenzwertigen beiträgen auf messenger
diensten oder plattform und strafbaren
handlungen aber das gegenteil ist leider
manchmal zumindest der fall allein diego
beschwerdestelle verzeichnete 2021 mit
8613 berechtigten fällen 50 prozent mehr
rechtsverstöße im internet als im
vorjahr und leider finden solche
rechtsverletzungen immer wieder neue
wege sich zu verbreiten daher erwarte
ich von der bundesregierung auch eine
dynamische anpassung des gesetzes sofern
sie notwendig ist da aber die im
bundestag eingegangenen anträge nach
außen eine gewisse fachliche richtigkeit
suggerieren es ist mir ein anliegen
einige dinge an dieser stelle nochmal
klarzustellen das kölner
verwaltungsgericht hat am ersten dritten
einer klage stattgegeben sondern über
eilanträge von google meter in beschluss
form entschieden das gericht hat
entschieden dass bei der einführung des
3a netz.de gegen das
herkunftslandprinzip verstoßen wurde und
die bundesregierung muss hier auch
sicherstellen das netz ag und die s
angepasst werden aber
gleichzeitig hat das gericht im
verfahren von meta den antrag in bezug
auf das gegen vorstellungs verfahren
nach entscheidungen über netz die
gehbeschwerden gelehnt denn die
vorschrift sei von der befugnisse der eu
mitgliedstaaten zur festlegung von
verfahren für die entfernung einer
information gedeckt und zusätzlich ist
auch ein verstoß gegen die charta der
grundrechte der europäischen union nicht
gegeben sich also wie die ard ist ja
gerade tut auf den beschluss des kölner
vgs zu berufen ist aus sicht der ard
eigentlich wenig konsequent dann ist
widerspricht der eigenen bewertung ihrer
fraktionen dieses gesetzes
möglicherweise hat die afg die
begründung des gerichts aber auch
einfach nicht zu ende gelesen
lassen sie mich zuletzt noch einen
gedanken mit auf den weg geben wir leben
in einer welt in der hass und hetze
unabhängig vom notwendigen
aufrechterhalten der meinungsfreiheit
jeden tag im internet und in sozialen
medien von uns erlebt wird mit
verheerenden auswirkungen vielleicht
wollten sie sich auch die frage stellen
ob gerade am heutigen tag der richtige
zeitpunkt ist die schützende hand über
telegramm zu halten wo der ukrainische
präsident uns von opfern des krieges
berichtet einem krieg der auch mit
gezielter desinformation online geführt
wird herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
für die spd fraktion hat der kollege
madschid körper methode sucht
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wer die
kolleginnen und kollegen stellen sie
sich vor in einer fernsehsendung würde
jemand erklären wie man
gesundheitsminister lauterbach im
vorbeigehen auf der autobahn per
kopfschuss töten könnt was würde bei
einem derartigen öffentlichen mordaufruf
passieren sagt verständlich große
empörung
strafanzeigen und strafrechtliche
konsequenzen gegen die verantwortlichen
und niemand würde hier auf die idee
kommen sich auf freie meinungsäusserung
zu berufen aber genau in dieser form
wurde der mordaufruf gegen den
gesundheitsminister als sprachnachricht
in einem telegramm gruppe geäußert und
es gibt offensichtlich menschen in
unserem land und auch in diesem hause
die das internet als rechtsfreien raum
sehen möchten ein raum in dem unser
recht und gesetz nicht gelten soll meine
damen und herren und da spreche ich vor
allem die urheber dieses unsinnigen
antrags an die meinungsfreiheit ist ein
fester bestandteil unserer demokratie
aber hass und aufruf zu straftaten sind
keine meinung werte kollegen im kollegen
es geht darum strafrechtlich relevantes
verhalten zu ahnden und es geht vor
allem darum menschen zu schützen und
straftaten zu den aufgerufen wird zu
verhindern kaum jemand würde im
öffentlichen raum außerhalb des internet
diese tötungsfantasien aussprechen die
täter verschanzte sich hinter anonymität
hetzen aber auch immer häufiger unter
klarnamen in leider viel zu schlecht
überwachten digitalen räumen wir sehen
in den letzten jahren zwei entwicklungen
erstens eine unfassbare eindämmung bei
gewaltfantasien und kriminellen gewalt
aufrufen und zweitens die traurige
erkenntnis dass diese hetze im netz
reale folgen in der realen nicht
digitalen welt hat bis hin zu
mordanschlägen auf repräsentanten
unserer demokratie und da sind wir auch
schon beim entscheidenden punkt
was strafbar ist und was nicht das
bestimmt die deutsche rechtsordnung und
da gibt es ganz klare regeln und gesetze
zum beispiel auf das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz ja dieses ist auch
für telegramm relevant denn wenn bis zu
200.000 menschen einen
kommunikationskanal hinzugefügt werden
können dann ist deshalb krank um kein
privater messenger dings mehr sondern
ein soziales netzwerk werte kolleginnen
und kollegen
und immerhin gab es zuletzt deutliche
verbesserungen im austausch mit dem in
dubai sitze in dem telegramm freuen
wurde das schon gesagt 64 von fast
durchsetzte kanäle wurden inzwischen
gelöscht das ist ein anfang aber eben
nicht mehr als ein anfang und
netzsperren können rechtlich und
technisch nicht die lösung sein da sind
wir uns mehrheitlich einig aber was
bleibt uns statt wir müssen den druck
erhöhen einerseits auf die anbieter und
zwar auch mit bußgeld an mit
bußgeldverfahren aber gerade auch der
europäische weg den wir mit dem digital
services act der eu derzeit geht sehr
viel versprechen das ist eine ganz
andere hausnummer als wenn nur
deutschland man ihn vor der tür steht
und andererseits müssen wir den druck
auf die täter erhöhen die
strafverfolgungsbehörden müssen da rein
in diesen sumpf und straftaten verfolgen
wir leben in einer zunehmend
digitalisierten welt die klassische
polizeiarbeit muss sich dieser welt
anpassen das erfordert vor allem mehr
personelle und technische ressourcen und
diese müssen wir und werden wir zur
verfügung stellen um diesem problem herr
zu werden vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
der letzte gegner hier zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt und zu dem antrag der
hf die fraktion
ist auch ein kommunikationsmittel der
demokratiebewegung beispielsweise auch
in belarus im iran war das so das haben
wir in der dieser bei debatte gehört der
messenger dienst ist allerdings in
deutschland als plattform für
rechtsextreme und radikale gegner von
corona maßnahmen massiv in der kritik
vor allem weil es keinen
zustellungsbevollmächtigten
beispielsweise gaben der strafbare
inhalte wo man strafbare inhalte melden
kann jetzt hat telegramm erste kanäle
gelöscht die debatte hier drehte sich
auch darum welche regeln braucht es zur
regulierung ohne meinungsfreiheit zu
beschränken der afg antrag der hier von
den anderen fraktionen kritisiert wurde
geht jetzt aber in die ausschüsse und
wird dort weiter beraten